Teachers are essential, are fundamental to build a society,...
...to build a future and to respond to present needs of all types of developments.
So the question is: "Are teachers important?"
The answer is obvious, teachers are essential.
The most complex issue and the most essential aspect...
...is linking the question with the answer.
And this is what we mean by a process.
It's a multidimensional process where we should address all aspects of teachers' development.
Social status of teachers, social conditions of teachers, salaries, training, retraining of teachers.
It's important to understand that when the country has been devastated...
...or struck by a tragedy like an earthquake or flood or war,...
...the first community we have to address to rebuild confidence and hope are the children.
They need to have a psychological support and education is the best way...
...to prove to these children that life is continuing,...
...that life doesn't stop despite the tragedy.
We need teachers who have a psychological capacity to deal with these tragedies...
...and to deal with these psychological challenges especially when you speak to children,...
...when you educate children, when you conduct them for their future.
It's not only transmitting knowledge, but also developing their own capacity...
...to be creative, to be optimistic and to prepare them to be citizens of their...
...community, of their country and of the world in the global dimension.